So far in this course, when you've
written SQL queries in the web-based
editor, we've hidden away the mechanism
that actually connects to a database and
runs your queries.
Some place back here, there's actually
a database running those queries.
Now, let's open up this box and
see how it actually works.
Behind our web server,
we're running Python code
that connects to an sqlite
database using DB-API calls.
The Python DB-API isn't a library.
It's a standard for
Python libraries that let's your
code connect to databases.
There are dozens of
different libraries for
different database systems
that follow this standard.
The standard specifies what functions
you'll call to connect to a database,
to send the queries and to get results.
So, if you learn the DB-API functions,
you can apply that knowledge
with any database system.
Although, the details of what each
database can do are different,
adapting Python code from one to
another is quite straightforward, but
each database system
has its own library.
And as you can see,
some of the library names are a little
bit different from the names of
the database systems that we work with.
For exercises in the browser,
we use the sqlite3 library.